[Applause]
Britney Spears and her boyfriend Sam
Mascari are stronger than ever
the two have been spending lots of time
together as the pop star continues to
focus on her health and happiness
amid the legal drama surrounding her
conservatorship case that's been a
roller coaster now a source tells ichi
that the reason the two worked so well
together is because they both encourage
and support each other through
everything the source adds sam is really
in love with Brittany he will always be
there to help in any way he can he's her
protector and while Britt Britt is an
international superstar when it comes to
time with her man the source says she's
just like us when they're together they
cook at home most nights they like to
keep things relaxed and simple it's fun
for me so what does Brittany like most
about Sam the source says she loves how
good he is with her kids Sean and Jaden
whom she shares with X hubby
Kevin Federline for Brittany being a
mother is the most important part of her
life her kids love when Sam is around
they have from the beginning of the
relationship he gets along with all of
them very well of course
Brittany hasn't been shy about showing
her love for Sam on social media on
Tuesday the singer gushed over being in
Miami with Mia more on Instagram Sam
shared another shot from their boat
excursion adorably calling Britt is
lioness in the caption the sweet posts
come just a day after Britney took to
her insta story to accuse the paparazzi
of altering pics to make her look bigger
no one ever really asks or the paparazzi
pictures fake into the paparazzi people
do stuff to the pictures and is the news
really real it's a conspiracy theory
that I'm actually interested in
yesterday I went swimming I look like a
40 pounds bigger than I am too
this is how I am right now and I'm
skinny as a needle